so like everything else it's going to be
an unusual super bowl but that has not
stopped the nfl from giving back to the
host city
our kevin martin is live in tampa this
morning with a look at how the league
has been giving back
all week long kevin good to see you
again this morning hi kevin
well good morning alex and john yeah
each super bowl week the
national football league makes it a
point to give back to the host city and
it's been no different
here in tampa for super bowl 55 if we
witnessed firsthand
them reach out and make an impact on
this community
when we come into town we're here to not
just play a game but to make an impact
as well
this entire week leading up to super
bowl sunday the nfl has made it a point
to get out in the tampa bay community
and give back to the host city the nfl
people think about the football game
and that is exciting but equally as
important as
the legacy projects that they're leaving
behind here the nfl has organized more
than 20 community
outreach events including donating
clothes to the crisis center of tampa
bay
we are part of the legal process so we
have to gather the evidence and
oftentimes that evidence is the clothing
that the individual is wearing when they
walk in the door
so to be able to provide them something
besides scrubs
uh something besides a a used t-shirt
or a pair of used shorts we're able to
provide brand new clothing
tags still on them in sizes that fit nfl
representatives as well as captain fear
the buccaneers team mascot
delivered over 100 items ranging from
sweatpants and sports bras to hats and
flip-flops and even journals that are
used as an emotional healing tool
for survivors i've sat with young women
and cried and i
understand that feeling but to be able
to give them new clothes
that's the beginning of the new start a
small gesture
that portrays a huge message i think
when an individual puts on something
that has the nfl logo on it the nfl is
showing that individual
in that moment that they're behind them
and that they believe
them
[Music]
and what a majority of these football
fans will remember from super bowl 55
will be the team
that hosts the lombardi trophy on the
field at raymond james stadium on sunday
night but for the hundreds and even
thousands of locals
the legacy goes far beyond the football
field reporting live in tampa kevin
martin
8 sports now hey kevin we've talked to
you live at several super bowls now
we know it's different in general what
have you seen that's different
since you've been there this week
yeah just because of the covet alone i
mean there's less people in town
um social distancing a majority of the
festivities and events are virtual this
year but i'll tell you what even though
with all the differences tampa bay has
done an unbelievable job it's still
making this
feel special you know still making it
feel like super bowl week like we're
leading up
to the big game on sunday yeah yeah
kevin
you know the pro bowl is supposed to be
here the nfl draft was supposed to be
here last year as well so we know the
nfl puts on a big product and do a lot
of community
work as well so good to see kevin and
enjoy the game
i know it we're going to talk to you
again live on sunday morning so thank
you so much
you have a great friday